smokes this is beautiful this is
incredible Bravo
the Vienna had no Organization for
managing their day-to-day operations so
I gave him the state-of-the-art system
to help with all their hotel operational
needs welcome to the web res pro system
and this will help transform your
business it will link up to the POS
system and it will give you data like
you've never had before bad news you
need to be organized from the Infantry's
to the wage costs to the salaries to the
POS systems to the checking in and the
checking out system I could see that
everyone was thrilled with the changes
at the Vienna just have a good look
round but as I watched Lisa
I noticed she was dissatisfied with the
renovations I was just seeing if it was
100% cotton is instead of pull out no it
doesn't need to be pull out and right
now I'm worried where Lisa's head is
going in to relaunch this evening I can
help you with your bags of purse let's
get you checked in while it was time to
relaunch the inn and restaurant yeah we
have an R I provided the staff with
brand new uniforms that go with the new
updated menu that includes wine pairing
and bear flights first is going to be
the Grateful then the second is going to
be the Pilsner
excuse me think you see Jamie I'm no
light bulb in there I just wanted to
don't worry about it okay
who's complaining about a light bulb
just making sure that they have enough
light with us trying to turn it over and
realized it later doesn't matter doesn't
matter let's focus on the big things are
you always like this our little details
like that I like to have things feel
right so I'm feeling extra like an extra
need to make sure everything's right
that's all
Oh tea tea yes sir OTT probably whatever
that means over the top over the top I
guess I don't have to be so over the top
now do i I do not what is wrong with her
tonight do you think she's gonna go back
to her old ways when I leave
she might accidentally cousins coming
welcome while Lisa is nitpicking
everything unnecessarily Jonathan is
lost in the kitchen and service is
starting to suffer what type would knock
was this please that is table number 11
- waiting on the two flank steaks with
it where's the flank steak are they
coming our moments minutes who's cooking
the flank steak come on guys we can do
one for top at the same time yes yes I
designed the menu around the size of the
kitchen the speed of ot working together
okay
come back for the flank where the hell
is this
look at me both yes both you cut the
[ __ ] okay look at me you're more capable
of doing four [ __ ] main courses at
the same time especially the two of you
and one of those main courses it's the
same dish we got to talk to each other
I'm not gonna start selling one dish at
a time from four top serious doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it on Jonathan
but look at me look at me I need some
[ __ ] effort from you a little bit I
need a little bit of respect a little
bit of effort from you okay yeah and
look at me you're the man hold this
[ __ ] thing together me then how'd you
go down the whole [ __ ] place is gonna
go down so did you step up okay I need
to talk a little bit
I don't want four main courses at the
same [ __ ] time and Jonathan yeah you
can get your mind set around four main
courses at the same [ __ ] time